[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم دعا الرئيس الفرنسي فرانسوا
اولاند مواطنيه الى الوحده الوطنيه التي
يعتبرها سلاح فرنسا الوحيد في مواجهه
التطرف وكانت مصادر قضائيه اكدت وقوع
حوادث لاطلاق نار على عده مساجد في فرنسا
منذ وقوع الهجوم على مقر صحيفه شارلي ابدو
نهار الاربعاء نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين ما مدى نجاعه السياسات الفرنسيه
لاحتواء التطرف في ضوء ما كشفه الاعتداء
على شارلي بدو وما تبعه من ردود يا
فعل وما هي المسؤوليات التي يرتبها وقوع
مثل هذه الاحداث على جميع الاطراف في ظل
الحديث عن ضروره التكاتف لمواجهه
[موسيقى]
التطرف في سياق ادانه الهجوم على صحيفه
شارلي بدو في باريس الذي وجهت اصابع
الاتهام فيه الى ثلاثه مسلمين اعرب اتحاد
المنظمات الاسلاميه في فرنسا عن مخاوفه من
ان يؤدي هذا الهجوم الى انعكاسات سلبيه
على الجاليه المسلمه مخاوف عن ما تاكدت
وجهتها مع ما ذكرته مصادر قضائيه عن حالات
اطلاق نار على مساجد في بعض مناطق فرنسا
رغم الدعوات الرسميه على اعلى المستويات
للتمسك بالوحده الوطنيه في مواجهه
التطرف على قدر هول الصدمه التي خلفها
الهجوم على صحيفه شارلي ابدو في العاصمه
الفرنسيه صباح الاربعاء يتحتم طرح الاسئله
غير المحببه في سياق كهذا تصوب فيه اصابع
الاتهام وربما الادانه الى اتجاه
واحد فمع اللحظات الاولى للحادث كانت اكثر
التفاصيل رواجا تلك التي اشارت الى جمل
سمعت على لسان منفذي الهجوم من قبيل لقد
انتقمنا للرسول وغيرها فضلا عن تصريحهم
بالانتماء للقاعده على نحو راه البعض
مثيرا للربا سترتاح دوائر وعقليات كثيره
داخل فرنسا وخارجها اذا وجه الاتهام الى
مسلمين ايا تكن اصولهم دون تجشم عناء
البحث عما وراء ذلك بفرض صحته فضلا عن
احتمال خطاه يقول مراقبون ان الاعلام
الغربي وليس الفرنسي فقط في حوادث مماثله
ينسب التهمه لدين المنفذ ان كان مسلما فقط
بينما يكتفي بوصف اليميني او المجرم ان
كان غير ذلك لكن ما لا ينبغي ان يضيع بحال
وسط ضجيج التداعيات الغاضبه هي اسئله
الحريات والاندماج المج جمعي فضلا عن
عواقب بعض السياسات الخارجيه في فرنسا
كمثال بوصفها مسرح الهجوم الاخير وواحه
حريه يراها كثيرون
مثاليه عرف عن الصحيفه المنكوبه التفاخر
باستفزاز الاديان السماويه بل سعيها
لمواطن الاحتقان بدليل اعاده نشر الرسوم
الدنماركيه المسيئه للنبي محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم عام 2006 رغم كل ما اثارت من
موجات غضب داميه عبر العالم وهو ما يعيد
طرح جدليه الحريه المسؤوله التي تتوقف عند
كرامات الاخرين
ومقدساتهم لانصار مسلك الصحيفه ردود هنا
قد يدحضها وجود خطوط حمراء في اتجاهات
اخرى اذا مس الامر معاداه الساميه او
الهولوكوست
مثلا هنا يطرح سؤال اخر عن دور الحكومات
في تدارك ممارسات كهذه مفخخه للاندماج
المجتمعي في بيئات متعدده الاصول كفرنسا
وما اذا كان مجديا اتفاء بخطاب ما بعد
الازمه الداعي لترسيخ التوحد كما طالب
الرئيس الفرنسي بعد ساعات من الهجوم دون
وقايه نسيج المجتمع من عوامل التمزق
العنصري الذي لا تؤمن بوائقه على الجاليات
الاسلاميه بعد نشر صور مشتبه بهما ينتميان
اليها وهو ما ظهرت بوادره سريعا في تكرار
حوادث الهجوم على مساجد في انحاء فرنسا
بعد ساعات فقط من حادث الهجوم
الدامي معنا في هذه الحلقه من باريس يفان
زوم ستاج مدير الدراسات السياسيه في معهد
ابسوس وعبد الكريم قطبي المدير العام
لاتحاد المنظمات الاسلاميه في فرنسا نرحب
بضيفنا نبدا بالسيد زوم ستاج ما جرى مع
شارلي ابدو هل كشف بعض الثغرات في سياسه
فرنسا لمواجهه التطرف في
البلاد
لا لا اعتقد ان ثم الثغرات او ربما نواقص
في التعامل فرنسا مع هذه الحوادث لم تعتد
فرنسا ان تتعرض لهذا النوع من الاعتداءات
الارهابيه بالتالي حتى لم تكن تتنبا به
وللمره الاولى منذ اكثر من 200 عام نشهد
هذا العدد من القتلى في فرنسا 12 قتيل هذا
نادر جدا بالتالي لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن
ثغرات فرنسا وضعت اليات وبرامج قضائيه
ايضا ومتصله بالشرطه قبت عدد من المتطرفين
المتدينين بغض النظر عن دينهم لكن لا يمكن
ان اتنبا بهذه الاحداث وفرنسا مصدومه لكن
من المبالغ به ان نعتبر ان ثم نقص في عمل
السلطات الفرنسيه او السياسه الفرنسيه
بشكل عام نعم سيد زوم انت هنا تتحدث عن
ثغرات امنيه ربما انا قصدت ما اذا كانت
المقاربه الشامله للدوله الفرنسيه في
التعامل مع امكانات التطرف في البلاد لم
تكن ربما موفقه تماما
تق بفرنسا يجب ان نعرف ان هذا البلد بشكل
اساسي هو بلد
علماني هذا داخل وصميم الشعار الفرنسي لكن
على مر العقود وربما القرون ترسخت فكره
العلمانيه وتطورت بشكل كبير في نهايه
المطاف كل مر حر بان يمارس الديانه التي
يختارها وهذا شخصي في اطار خصوصي من وجه
النظر هذه لطالما قبلنا الاديان كما هي
تمت تطرف ديني يظهر بشكل اكبر ولا سما
الانطواء على الهويه من قبل الذين يعيشون
في فرنسا كان على المستوى السياسي او
الاجتماعي او الديني لكن فكره فكره
التسامح المتصله بالممارسه دينيه لطالما
كانت قائمه فرنسا بلد علماني وهو متسامح
جدا مع الاديان المختلفه
وكان من التعقيد بمكان ومن الصعب بمكان
بالنسبه للسلطات الفرنسيه ان تقول مثلا
انتم تمارسون ديانت ولكنكم تتشدد وتصبحون
اكثر تطرفا ونحن نعارض ذلك لان مره اخرى
التسامح هي قيمه قائمه متجره في المجتمع
الفرنسي ولا سيما التسامح الديني لكن ما
شاهدناه على مار السنين هو فعلا تطرف عدد
من الاصوليين كان ذلك متطرفين من اليمين
المسيحي او كذلك متطرفين اسلاميين اذا حتى
الان فرنسا لم تكن تريد فعلا ان تذهب
بعيدا في القمع وفي التعاطي مع هذه
الحركات العنصر الجديد الذي ظهر منذ
الربيع العربي وما رايناه ايضا في عدد من
البلدان اشير تحديدا الى سوريا والعراق
راينا عددا من الشبان الفرنسيين اصولهم
مغربيه او لا هؤلاء ذهبوا لكي يحاربوا في
هذين البلدين السلطه الفرنسيه اليوم ربما
ضائع بعض الشيء ولم تعتمد استجابه ملائمه
لانها لا تدرك كيفيه اداره هؤلاء الذين
يعدون بعد ان يكون قد تطرف وربما لا
ينتمون الى شبكات منظمه ولكن طبعا نعرف ما
قد يقومون به في ضوء هذا الاعتداء الاخير
والحوافز التي تدفعهم هؤلاء الناس ربما
كما قلت لا ينتمون الى شبكات يمكن للدوله
الفرنسيه ان ترصدها احيانا يكونون يعملون
بمفردهم ويصعب على الدوله كما قلت ان
تحتوي هذا التهديد او هذا الخطر ان نتحدث
عن ثغرات هو مبالغ فيه من وجهه نظري لانه
مره اخرى مساد اذا هي العلمانيه في مكان
والفصل بين الدين والدوله ولكن ايضا تسامح
كبير بالنسبه لمن يمارسون عقيدتهم ودينهم
ما لا نحسم القيام به حتى الان هو معرض او
احتواء اولئك الذين يتطرفون بشكل سريع هذا
يتم في بضعه اشهر في الواقع اي عندما
ينقلب الناس ممارسه عاديه الى ممارسه
ترفيه و متطرفه وايضا عنف انت محق في هذه
النقطه فرنسا لم تكن جاهزه للتطرق الى ذلك
ولكن هل هل هناك تفسير سيد عبد الكريم
قطبي سيد عبد الكريم
قطبي هل هناك اي
تفسير
لوجود ارجو ان تكون تسمعني سيد
قطبي الو تسمعني سيد
قطبي اسمعك لكن الصوت ضعيف جدا ضعيف نحول
تعيد السؤال نحاول ان نحسنه نحاول ان
نحسنه هل هناك تفسير سيد قطبي لظاهره ان
هناك شباب من اصول مسلمه مغاربيه في
العموم ولدوا في فرنسا تربوا في فرنسا
ربما لم يزوروا في حياتهم بلدان ابائهم
واجدادهم ولكن مع ذلك ورغم التعليم
الفرنسي والبيئه الفرنسيه
ربما يقدمون على اعمال تبدو نشاز
في الفهم والثقافه
الفرنسيه انا لم اسمع السؤال جيد لكن على
كل حال ربما سمعت بق بعض مقتطفات من
السؤال فعلى كل حال الان تحريات يعني
جاريه
ولا حتى الان لم يكتشف يعني منفذي هذه
الهجمات لكن على كل حال كل اصابع تشير على
ان هناك شباب من من المسلمين هم الذين
قاموا بهذه العمليه وهذه العمل الاجرامي
الذي حقيقه كل المسلمين وكل المنظمات
الاسلاميه اذانه بشده الاسباب صراحه التي
تجعل ان كثير او من الشباب هؤلاء الان
ينحون ويمشون في هذا التوجه توجه يعني
التطرف والتشدد يعني في اسباب كثيره هناك
اسباب اجتماعيه هناك اسباب يعني متعلقه
بالاشخاص انفسهم فحسب الان بعد الدراسات
التي اجريت هنا في فرنسا وفي كذلك في
بركسل ان كثير من هؤلاء الشباب الان
يعتنقون هذه الافكار المتشدده عن طريق
الانترنت فاغلبهم الان لا يراود المساجد
بل حتى اذا ارادوا مراو المساجد يعني
قليله جدا فاغلبهم اما منقطعين عن
الدراسه او يعيشون على هامش المجتمع
ويعتنقون هذه الافكار المتشدده من خلال
الانترنت ومن خلال هذه الشبكات
الاجتماعيه ه يعني عفوا عفوا هل هل ترى
يعني هل ترى فيما يقدمون عليه نوع من
الثار من مجتمع لم يستطيعوا الاندماج فيه
بشكل
جيد صحيح هناك هذا هذا هذا الشعور ان عند
كثير من الشباب ان الذي نلتقي بهم فعندهم
شعور كذلك من رده الفعل نحو هذا المجتمع
لانهم يعتقدون انهم جزء من هذا المجتمع لا
يتجزا من هذا المجتمع هم ابناء من هذا
المجتمع هم فرنسيون وطبعا عندهم خصوصيه
دينيه وثقافيه مسلمون لكن يشعرون ان هذا
المجتمع يرفضهم سواء من خلال طبعا يعني
الشغل من خلال كذلك الفرص الشغل او من
خلال عده امور فهم يعتنقون ويعتقدون ان
المجتمع يرفضهم فبالتالي هذا يدفعه بعض
منهم الى
هذا ردود الفعل وقد تكون ردود الفعل مع مع
الاسف الشديد يعني يعني فيها عنف وفيها
طبعا يعني شده
يرفضها المبادئ الدين وقيم الاسلام ويرفض
كذلك المنطق والواقع لكن كثير من الشباب
مع الاسف يعني يعتقدون ان المجتمع يرفضهم
وينبذ وبالتالي هذه رده فعل يعني ك لهم عن
طريق هذا التصرف او هذا الشعور الذين ي
شعرونه يعني في في المجتمع هنا نعم موضوع
الاندماج سيد زوم
مطروح باستمرار في في فرنسا هل تعتقد ان
به اشكاليه كبيره لان هؤلاء مطلوب منهم
الاندماج في الثقافه الفرنسيه وفي القيم
الفرنسيه وفي نفس الوقت هم يشعرون بانهم
لا احد عمليا يرغب في اندماجهم بل هم
يعاملون باستمرار على انهم ليسوا فرنسين
فرنسيين حتى وان
كان جد الاول من اصول غير
فرنسيه
كذلك لكن لا اعتقد قضيه الاندماج بالنسبه
لبعض المغتربين والشباب تحديدا ليست قضيه
جديده في فرنسا وهي لا تعود الى بضع
السنوات منذ فتره طويله هذا ما نسميه
فرنسا بشباب الجيل الثاني والجيل الثالث
اي اولئك الذين ولدوا في فرنسا واجدادهم
هم الذين بمعظمهم اتوا من شمال افريقيا
ومن المغرب اذا هم الذين اتوا الى فرنسا
وهذه مشكله لكن بالنسبه لعدد منهم لكن
تذكروا انه بين
ملايين ومئات الالاف المغاربه وشباب
المغاربه في فرنسا عدد كبير منهم نجحوا
بالاندماج بايجاد وظيفه تلائم توقعاتهم
اذا هذا الجدل ليس جديدا في فتره ما كنا
نتحدث في فرنسا بشكل اساسي عن مبالغه في
تمثيل المغاربه في صفوف اولئك الذين
يواجهون مشاكل مع السلطه لكن لا اعرف اذا
كانت هذه الارقام صحيحه نعم ربما عندما
تكون مغربيا شابا الفرصه بان تقع في
الانحراف ربما هي اكبر لكن هذا قد ادى الى
جدل وهذا ما ادى ايضا الى ظهور وزياده
تواجد الجبهه الوطنيه تعرفون ان اليمين
الفرنسي المتطرف لا سما لا يحبذ اذا هؤلاء
الشباب المهم في نهايه المطاف ان نتذكر ان
اقليه من هؤلاء يقعون في العنف العنف
السياسي او ايضا العنف الذي رايناه بالامس
في شغلي ابدو هذا لا يمثل الا اقليه بسيطه
جدا من اولئك وهذا ما يبقى في اذهان
الفرنسيين وسلطات الفرنسيه هؤلاء الشباب
الذين لا يتمكنون من الاندماج هم الذين
يقعون في اسلام اكثر تطرفا قبل 20 او 25
عاما اتذكر مثلا مغربي او شاب مغربي لم
يكن اكثر تدينا من فرنسي عادي لدينا شباب
من اصول عربيه او مسلمه ربما يختارون حتى
لا يتدين اليوم نرى انه بالنسبه للاقليه
اقول مره اخرى هؤلاء اذا يذهبون الى
التدين وهذا حق للجميع حق ان يمارس ديانته
ا كانت اليهوديه او المسيحيه او الاسلام
في فرنسا لكن ما هو جديد هو انه بالنسبه
لي جزء منهم العنف العنف السياسي او العنف
الفعلي يصبح شيئا مشروعا وهذا خطر جدا في
المجتمع الفرنسي هذا ما كنت اقوله قبل
قليل لان المجتمع الفرنسي ليس جاهزا
للتعاطي مع هذا النوع من الامور المتطرفين
من الاديان المختلفه نعم كانوا متواجدين
في فرنسا ولكن ليس بهذه ال ونحن ندرك الان
ان عدد من الشبان يقعون في التطرف
حوالي ال000 من الشباب الفرنسيين يحاربون
اليوم في سوريا والعراق وهذه مشكله وايضا
لكي نحاول فهم ما يجري في فرنسا يجب ان
نتذكر ان اولئك الذين يلجؤون الى اسلام او
الى تطرف اسلامي احيانا قد لا يكونون اصلا
من اصول عربيه او مغربيه بعضهم هم من
فرنسيين عاديين ليس لديهم اي اصول او
علاقه لا بالعروبه ولا بالاسلام هذا جديد
جدا وهذا ايضا لم تتنبا به او لم تتوقعه
ولم تفهمه السلطات الفرنسيه لماذا لا يمكن
ان نفهم اليوم لماذا نجد ان شابا نشا في
مجتمع مسيحي عادي يذهب الى الاسلام
والاسلام المتطرف تحديدا نعم ثمت مشكله
اندماج ولكن هذه المشكله ليست جديده ما هو
جديد واكرر هو هذا العنف والعنف السريع
جدا ولهذا نريد ان ان نعرف بعد الفاصل ما
المطروح الان على المجتمع الفرنسي وطبقته
وطبقته السياسيه ل مواجهه هذه الظاهره لن
عوده الى هذه النقطه بعد فاصل نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الجهود التي
تبذلها فرنسا
لمواجهه التطرف السيد السيد عبد الكريم
القطبي ا ضيفنا قبل قليل اشار اكثر من مره
اشار اكثر من مره الى ان هؤلاء الذين
يقومون بهذا النوع من الممارسات هم اقليه
واكد على موضوع الاقليه اكثر من مره برايك
كيف يمكن ان تطرح القضيه دائما على انها
اقليه ولا يمكن ان تشوه البقيه اي
الاغلبيه رجع الايربيس لصقها منيح في
السما دير بالك دير بالك ما تنسانيش دائما
الكاميرا
اطلع سيد قطبي ارجو ان تكون سمعت سؤالي
والا سعيده سيد قطبي
تسمعني واضح انه لا يسمعني للاسف سنعود
الى السيد زوم ستاج مره اخرى في انتظار
معالجه هذا الاشكال الذي اثر على طبيعه
الجدل بين الضيفين نعتذر عن ذلك سيد زوم
ستاك طالما اشرت ان الموضوع يتعلق باقل
طالما يتعلق
باقل لماذا احيانا هناك بعض
الاوساط في فرنسا او في غيرها يرومون
التعميم فبالتالي تصبح موضوع الاقليه
وكانه وكانه يتعلق بالاغلبيه
ككل اذا بعيدا عن الاعتداء وعن مقتل عدد
كبير من الناس هذا ما ذكرتم ونعم من
التداعيات التي هي مهمه جدا في هذا
المجتمع الفرنسي حتى لو ان السياسيين دعوا
الى الابتعاد عن التعميم فبالنسبه لشريحه
من الناس الفرنسيين انهم المسلمون الذين
سوف يقعون ضحيه كل ذلك و نشهد من يقول ان
المسلمين بشكل عام هم الذين يتطرفون هذا
غير صحيح طبعا ولكن بعض الفرنسيين قد
يعتقدون ذلك ويقولون عندها سوف يصعب
التعايش مع مسلمين يزدادون ترفا هذا ما
نسمعه في الشارع اليوم هذا ما اسمعه انا
ايضا في عملي وفي الفرق وفي اطار بحوثنا
حول التدين في فرنسا يقال لنا المسلم
المعتدل لا يوجد اصلا لم يعد موجودا هذا
ما نسمعه بمعنى اخر عندما يكون
للفرنسيين صوره عن الاسلام او عن المسلمين
يربطون بين ذلك والتطرف ويعتبرون ان ما من
اسلام معتدل هذا هو الخطر الحقيقي وهذا
يتج تسامحهم الاان بشم الاس تحدا ولكن سيد
زوم يعني هل هل هناك في الاوساط الفرنسيه
بعض النقاش لان ربما ربما اقول فرنسا لم
تكن لتتعرض لهذا النوع من التحدي في
السنوات الماضيه ربما تعرضت له الان لانها
اصبحت اكثر تورتا في مالي في مواجهه
الجماعات المتطرفه في سوريا وفي العراق
وبالتالي اقحمت نفسها في دائره
ربما بعض شرار هذه المواجهه وصلها
الان هذا في نهايه المطاف قرار سياسي
فرنسا قررت ان تكون موجوده على عدد من
الجبهات وان تتدخل كما ذكرتم في مالي
وايضا في العراق ليس في سوريا وتدخلها
محصور في العراق هذا قرار صادر عن الرئ
الفرنسي وهذا موقف تتقاسمه الاطراف
السياسيه المختلفه والجمهور الفرنسي نحن
مع تدخل الجيش الفرنسي في الساحل والصحراء
وتحديدا في مالي هذا قرار سياسي يجب ان
نتحمل تداعياته نعم تعرضت فرنسا لتداعيات
بشكل موجع ومؤلم لكن هذا امر يجب ان
تعرفوا انه مقبول من قبل الطبقه السياسيه
في فرنسا والفرنسيين بشكل اعم هذه تداعيات
لهذا القرار كما قلنا الا اننا او ان
الفرنسيين هم مع هذا القرار ويدعمون رئيس
الجمهوريه فيما يتعلق بالتدخل او يتدخل
بلدنا في الشرق الاوسط او في شمال افريقيا
سيد قطبي ما المطلوب تحديدا من المسلمين
الان في هذه المرحله لمواجهه هذا الجدل
الدائر حولهم وحول طبيعه اندماجهم وطبيعه
تصرفاتهم في المجتمع
الفرنسي والله الان المطلوب طبعا احنا
دائما رسائلنا الى المسلمين ا على اساس
دائما مزيد من الاندماج الايجابي داخل
المجتمع على ان يكونوا على ان يكونوا طبعا
مواطنين صالحين في المجتمع وان يشاركوا في
تنميه المجتمع وفي الحفاظ على امن هذا
المجتمع وكذلك مزيد من التشبت بقيمهم
وبدينه وبثقافة
بداخل المجتمع والمشاركه الايجابيه
الفعاله والمؤثره في هذا المجتمع طبعا ال
ما نطالبه نطالبهم اكثر الان وعلى اساس ان
يكونوا طبعا حاضرين طبعا في معاملاتهم في
سلوكهم انلا يكون طبعا سلوكهم سلوك يعني
يريب او قد يتنافى مع قيم الاسلام او قد
ما يجر لهم بعض المخاطر فلذلك الان اليوم
يعني وجهنا رساله الى كل المؤسسات
والجمعيات والمراكز الاسلاميه خاصه رؤساء
الجمعيات والائمه على ان يكون غدا يعني في
كل خطب الجمعه ان يتناولوا هذا الحدث وان
يدينوا بشده هذا الاعتداء ثم ان يتكلموا
عن سماحه الاسلام وعن وسطيه الاسلام و
اعتدال الاسلام وان يكون المسلمون يعني
عناصر بناءه
فعاله تشيع روح السلام
وال التعايش السلمي داخل هذا المجتمع وان
يكون بعد كل صلاه بعد صلاه الجمعه عفوا ان
تكون تجم عات يعني
حول المساجد يعني تعبيرا لرفضهم لهذا هذا
الحدث هذا الاعتداء الذي ذهب على اثره
ارواح وكذلك تضامن مع كل مكونات المجتمع
الفرنسي نعم بالطبع الادانات هي القاسم
المشترك تقريبا الان بين كل الفرنسيين
حكومه واحزابا وقوه سياسيه وبالطبع
المسلمون لكن في هذه الحاله سيد قطبي كيف
يمكن للجاليه المسلمه ان تتجاوز الاد
وايضا تتجاوز ما يمكن وصفه بنوع
من اللهجه الاعتذار وكان كل المسلمين
يشعرون بانهم كانهم هم المتهمون في كل ما
قاموا به هؤلاء الثلاثه او الاربعه
والخمسه لان القضيه ايضا بها بها نقطه
اشكاليه
يعني وهذا بحقيقه هذا هو التحدي مع الاسف
يعني امام الوجود الاسلامي هنا في فرنسا
بالخصوص ان كلما وقع حدث مع الاسف ووجهت
اصابع اتهام المسلمين فالمسلمين في كل
حاله وفي كل دائما عليهم ان يعبروا عن
رفضهم وعن وكانهم يتبرؤون من كل طبعا هذا
التبرؤ بالنسبه لنا المسلمين احنا عندنا
ما في مشكله ل نحنا كانسان وكم مسلمين
نرفض هذا العنف وهذا الاعتداء رغم من كل
من صدر وخاصه اذا صدر من المسلمين لان هذا
يسيء الى صوره الاسلام والمسلمين يعني
بشده ولكن في نفس الوقت نحن نوجه رساله
كذلك الى المجتمع الفرنسي والى يعني كذلك
الاداره الفرنسيه وقلنا لابد كذلك من
الاداره الفرنسيه ان تتحمل مسؤوليتها طبعا
في الحفاظ على كل كل يعني ماكل العباده
للمسلمين لان المسلمون الان صاروا في نفس
الوقت ضحيه واليوم يعني كانت اعتداءات على
عده مساجد وعلى عده يعني يعني عده مسلمين
ومسلمات في بعض المسلمات يعني
يعني رفضوا يعني رفعوا من فوق رؤسنا
الحجاب وهذا طبعا مع الاسف صار يتنامى
فقلنا كذلك لابد للمسلمين ان يحترموا ان
تحترم عقيدتهم وشعرهم وان لا يكون هذا مع
الاسف هذه الالفاظ المشينه الذي اصبحنا
يعني مع الاسف نراها كل يوم في وسائل
الاعلام التي تحقر من المسلمين ومن وتشكك
في مواطنتهم وكانهم مواطنون من الدرجه
الثانيه في هذه في هذا المجتمع فالمسؤول
مشتركه من طرف المسلمين لابد طبعا ان
يكونوا وهذا من نطالبهم واعتقد ان اغلب
المسلمين يعني في هذا المجتمع يعني
مواطنون صالحون يشاركون يعني في المجتمع
تمنون الخير لهذا المجتمع لكن بالجهه
الاخرى كذلك على الجهات المسؤوله وعلى
الطرف الاخر كذلك ان يعتبر ان المسلمين هم
شركون لهم في هذا المجتمع في بناء هذا
المجتمع وفي ازدهار المجتمع وفي بناء
اعتقد هذا السلم الاجتماعي داخل هذا
المجتمع شكرا جزيلا لك سيد عبد الكريم
قطبي المدير العام لاتحاد المنظمات
الاسلاميه في فرنسا شكرا ايضا لضيفنا
ستيفان زوم ستج مدير الدراسات السياسيه في
معهد ابسوس بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه
هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله